[主播] 为什么会推荐孩子们经常去读《鄂尔古纳河右岸》以及《狼图腾》这种这种书呢？
[主播] 《狼图腾》那个书签有吗？
[嘉宾] 没有。
[主播] 我们在自然中获得，也在自然中失去。
[主播] 说得对吧？
[主播] 对吧？你看我们所收割的粮食是不是自然中获得？
[主播] 我们采摘的果降果是不是自然中获得？
[主播] 当然我们也在自然中失去。
[主播] 一次大的洪水，一次大的灾害是不是也失去了？
[主播] 我们在自然中获得，我们也在自然中失去。
[主播] 我们在山林中相遇。
[主播] 我们也在山林中分别。
[主播] 很真实吧？
[主播] 如果大家看过那套书的话，这个书里头讲的那个主人公，他就是跟他的丈夫在山林之间相遇。
[主播] 我们在自然中获得，也在自然中失去，我们在山林中相遇，也在山林中分别。
[主播] 人们的爱恨情仇都是与山林相关的。那些尊重自然的人，热爱自然的人。那些尊重并且热爱自然的人，他们是能从自然中获取难以想象的快乐。在他们眼睛里，岩石上的壁画。岩石上的壁画。山间的溪流。枝头的明月。枝头的明月。都充满了美感。如果你难过了，你就站在山巅。你就感受山风吹过。难过的时候，你就把你的心事诉说给山风去听。将心事诉说给山风。你记得那个书里头描绘吧？我现在努力的回忆书里头讲过的情节。就他很难过的时候，然后呢他的，比如说他的父亲被闪电劈中了。然后还有后来的那个萨满，他每次在救别人的时候失去了自己的孩子。他就很沉默的站在山山风里头，也不怎么说话，对吧？当你难过了，你就把你的心事诉说给山风。当你遗憾了，你，你就把你的遗憾托付给流水。就把你的痛苦托付给托付给流水。山风从来不语。流水也从来不争。但是他们却像一个寂寞陪伴你身边的朋友一样，让你心情愉悦。在那些尊重自然，热爱自然的人的眼里头，栖息的驯鹿。奔腾的河流。月光下起舞的萨满，他们的文化，对吧？还有呢，在篝火旁饮酒纵歌的人们。这个就是爱与光明。这个就是快乐与放松。所以，我特别喜欢让孩子们感受来自大自然纯净的东西。产自大兴安岭林场里头，清晨带着露珠裹着白霜的野生蓝莓。采摘回来之后呢，打磨成原浆。不加一滴水。野生的确实有一点点的酸涩感，实际上。如果我给它加上糖，加上蜂蜜，或者加上一些人工养殖的蓝莓，它的口感可能会更好。但是我不想修饰。让山风有山风的样子，让流水有流水的样子。让明月有明月的样子，这样孩子才能有孩子的样子。爱情才能有爱情的样子。快乐才有快乐的样子，自然也才有自然的样子。如果您喜欢，可以加些蜂蜜，可以加些糖，加些糖浆都行，OK?野生蓝莓原浆啊，产自大兴安岭的林区。但是它也有一些现实意义，如果说人们能够自己家里跑到山林里去采摘小的果子而收益的时候，人们就不会去砍伐树木。对吗？当人们能在老家里找到一个力所能及，而且还能够差不多养家糊口的方式的时候，他就不背景离乡。是不是？所以农业是一个很大的产业链，只要你在这个产业链里头，你不管你挣不挣钱，一定有人能挣钱。这就是农业的快乐。就是独乐了不如众乐了呀。因为它产业链足够长，而且这个产业链上的从业人口足够多，所以但凡你只要还在这个产业里头在努力，一定就是在做善事。那当然同时呢，大家看。
[主播] 共同这套书，藏在地图里的中国国家地理。
[主播] 我说讲地理的时候必须拿地图来说。
[主播] 地图是地理的语言。
[主播] 就像文字是人类的语言一样。
[主播] 单个的一张地图并不具有说服力。
[主播] 就像我给大家再举个例子。
[主播] 我刚说了单个的。
[主播] 你家有一张地图呢，它没有大量的信息的补充，没有故事的讲解。
[主播] 没有人文和历史，文化和建筑的点缀，那个地图毫无意义。甚至你们家买地球仪，你看前段我们给大家找地球仪是扫开有一个AR软件能够解释，能够参与，能够互动的东西。
[主播] 因为单纯的一个东西放那块地图或者地球仪，你不会喜欢的，你觉得它索然无味，对吗？
[主播] 索然无味。
[主播] 为什么索然无味呢？
[主播] 因为。
[主播] 它无法引发人的想象，无法引发人的共感。
[主播] OK?
[主播] 有朋友说董老师的人数都掉十万加了，赶快人气票。
[主播] 没事，没事，没事。
[主播] 大家比我还着急啊。没事。
[主播] 不影响。
[主播] 你要让大家要休息一下。
[主播] 大家跟你听了这么长时间了。休息休息。
[主播] 而且到了周末，家长们把手机放下，真的带孩子去一趟这个，比如说去一趟艺术馆，去一趟博物馆。很多城市的博物馆和艺术馆可能甚至都是免费的，如果当地人申请的话。
[主播] 然后呢，到傍晚的时候散一散步，对吧？跑一跑步。
[主播] 然后呢，或者我们直播间里昨天不是卖牛排了吗？
[嘉宾] 今天也有。
[主播] 今天也有牛排。
[主播] 牛排收到了之后煎一下。
[主播] 然后给上面撒上黑胡椒和盐。
[主播] 然后煎一点点小小的番茄摆在旁边。
[主播] 一盘很精致的餐饭，你们俩坐在一起把饭吃完，然后一个聊一起聊聊天。
[主播] 多美好的过程啊。
[主播] 对吧？比比我来比来直播间听我在这胡说八道有用多了，有意义多了。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 我我比较鼓励大家去过现实中的生活。
[主播] 东方真选就是你愿意有时间了，没事了，你想来听听，平常其实不用一直在这。
[主播] 然后这个缺什么了，你看来有需要的，你觉得合适的，你买，不需要不合适，你在这不买也行。
[主播] 有朋友昨天跟我说，董老师这个我在抖音上看到了很多批评你的。我感到很难过。
[主播] 黑粉，很难过。
[主播] 然后说我在这买了好多东西。
[主播] 我要支持你。
[主播] 其实我听到这句话首先是感动。
[主播] 好人真多。
[主播] 但第二个我就觉得很自责，就是你支持我。
[主播] 我感觉到有愧。
[主播] 这第一个。
[主播] 我没有那么好。
[主播] 第二个呢，如果您喜欢，真的喜欢这种气氛。
[主播] 你在这待一待就行了。
[主播] 东西合适，你需要你再买，不需要不合适，你不买都行。
[主播] 千万不能说支持东西会的方式，就是在这一直花钱。
[主播] 那那就错了，那就跟我的想做的事情完全背离了。
[主播] OK?
[主播] 需要再买啊。
[主播] 一定是按需购买和理性消费。
[主播] OK?嗯。
[主播] 想要的朋友自己拍啊。
[嘉宾] 枸杞。
[主播] 野生蓝莓原浆啊。
[主播] 刚才推荐的这套书叫国家地理，中国国家地理。
[主播] 这套书还比较好。
[主播] 我从昨天到今天一直在翻这些书。
[主播] 就是你如果很敏锐的能够捕捉信息的话，你其实能发现很多浪漫的。
[主播] 地理啊，书籍。
[主播] 我给大家讲的是书籍。
[主播] 然后你可以自己去买。
[主播] 我说。
[主播] 很多的浪漫其实是需要你自己去感知，而且给孩子描述的。
[主播] 你看我昨天讲到了，当然还有另外两本书叫《长江》和《黄河》啊，大量的其实都是带着图片的，可以跟孩子一起亲子共读的书。
[主播] 昨天我在讲到这套书的时候。
[主播] 我讲到了黄河。
[主播] 我讲到了我们要在兰州的一大早赶上一碗这个牛肉面。
[主播] 那个沸腾的汤里头。
[主播] 再浇上一些辣椒油。
[主播] 然后趁得很开很劲道的面，吃一口真的特别满足。
[主播] 浑身都舒服。
[主播] 然后当然你从兰州一路再往下走，还有很多特别好的城市。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 我说的不一定非在黄河边，可能是黄河沿岸也行。
[主播] 然后大家当然也知道宁夏。
[主播] 宁夏的滩羊，这两天入伏了。
[主播] 其实我们传统的饮食文化里头是入伏天吃羊肉的，你知道吧？
[嘉宾] 不知道。
[嘉宾] 冬天吃。
[主播] 冬天当然可以吃。
[主播] 其实我们饮食文化里头入伏天也吃羊肉的。
[主播] 嗯，真的。
[主播] 不知道吧？
[主播] 这个当然这个直播间不能多说，因为中医里头的一些东西可能牵扯到一些大家容易误解为功效的宣传。
[主播] 但是只是传统的饮食习惯而已。
[主播] 饮食文化而已。
[主播] 知道了吧？现在知道了吧？嗯。
[主播] 所以到了这两天吃姜。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 然后呢吃羊。
[主播] 吃一些。
[嘉宾] 冬吃萝卜夏吃姜。
[主播] 对对对对。
[主播] 冬吃萝卜夏吃姜。
[主播] 还有一种就是。
[主播] 朋友说赶快卖货。
[主播] 我再卖货，再卖货啊。
[主播] 再卖货，卖这个书呢。
[主播] 然后到了宁夏。
[主播] 从宁夏一路过去，还有很多特别好的城市。
[主播] 你到西安呀，对吧？
[主播] 到河南啊。
[主播] 然后昨天我在这里讲到了很多，我说我有很多特别好的河南的朋友。
[主播] 你看黄河在上游对于宁夏河套平原，它是非常温和的，很少泛滥。
[主播] 然后呢，很平坦的冲击扇，土壤细腻，而且肥沃，相对也湿润。
[主播] 所以呢，天赋河套呀。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 当然黄河到了下游，你在河南就经常泛滥。
[主播] 所以其实我昨天在这提过一段话。
[主播] 我其实是无心的提那段话，我提那段话只是因为真的想到我身边很多的好好的河南朋友而已。
[主播] 但是我今天早上有一个朋友跟我私信发了那个视频，而且是好多好多人跟我私信发了。
[主播] 就我说，我说我身边有特别好的河南的朋友。
[主播] 然后我有很多的亲戚甚至也在河南生活。
[主播] 我很喜欢那片土地。
[主播] 然后我也很对那片土地上生活的人们感到亲亲近。
[主播] 因为黄河在下游经常泛滥，如果大家去查一下河南历史上那些灾难就能理解了。
[主播] 包括大家离这非常近的，对吧，当年为了阻止日军的往前进攻的脚步，把花园口直接炸开。
[主播] 那都是我们的兄弟姐妹啊，那是我们的同胞啊。
[主播] 他们也因此受难了。
[主播] 所以多灾多难。
[主播] 但也就是这种特别艰苦的，多灾多难的环境里头，你会发现他们非常的坚毅，勇敢。
[主播] 而且极其的勤劳和朴实。
[主播] 我的天哪。
[主播] 我身边认识的这些河南的朋友们都特别的勤快，而且对人极其热情大方。
[主播] 就他自己有五块钱，他都愿意给你花四块九的那种感觉。
[主播] 每次吃饭的时候从来不让你掏钱。
[主播] 然后去你家里，去他家里的话，全家人张罗给你做一大桌子菜。
[主播] 然后我曾经一直期待着，因为我我跟他们聊了很多，我就一直期待着跟他们去一趟他们老家体验过年的气氛。
[主播] 就是一过年，一群后生们，然后就去长辈家里头一个一个的挨著磕头，然后种种就一直种。
[主播] 就是那种短特别的短平快的语言，又特别亲切和爱，热心肠的这种人的性格，让我们感觉到了这其实就是属于黄河可能连你带杀的那种环境里头所孕育出来的一种质朴而又真诚的情感。
[主播] 所以你看，读这一套书呢，我们不仅在了解这个历史。
[主播] 对吧，我们其实也更在通过地理，我们也更加的通过地理，其实了解了沿河所有城市和省份人们的风土人情。
[主播] 那当然大家到了山东，我的天哪，山东人们也极其的热情。
[主播] 我之前去过山东这个演讲，我去过聊城。
[主播] 去过，对，好客山东啊。
[主播] 去过临清。
[主播] 去过济南。
[主播] 去过阳谷。
[主播] 阳谷县知道吧？
[主播] 就是武松打虎那地方。
[主播] 阳谷县。
[主播] 还去过好多年前这个出差去过这个济南。
[主播] 去过山东很多地方。
[主播] 你说，然后当然这个榴莲不是之前在山东青岛吗？
[主播] 晚上去吃饭。
[主播] 他们的菜呢，价格就是。
[主播] 当然跟北京相比，我之前说我喜欢威海，我说威海在海边特别干净，物价还不高，然后朋友说私信说董老师威海还不高。
[主播] 我当然因为我可能我生活经验比较低啊，我跟北京相比的话，其实还行。
[主播] 然后呢，这个东西又好吃。
[主播] 价格又公道。
[主播] 一大盘你根本吃不完。
[主播] 我们当时不知道，有时候在，比如说中关村附近的饭店里头，因为中关村附近饭店他们的房租成本高嘛。
[主播] 点菜的量。
[主播] 点了那么多盘。
[主播] 吃不完。
[主播] 但是每一个都特别好吃，就是他用这个小麦面粉做的那个像烙的饼一样，是一个鱼的样子。
[嘉宾] 鱼。
[主播] 越吃越好吃。
[主播] 吃不完之后带走。
[主播] 然后呢，炒的那个正好是四月多，炒那个香椿鸡蛋。
[主播] 那么大一盘。
[主播] 然后黄瓜和那个扇贝还是什么，拌的凉菜。
[主播] 然后煮的那个丝瓜还有什么，都是海鲜的汤，因为你在青岛嘛，是什么都有海鲜。
[主播] 哎哟，真好吃。
[主播] 太好吃了。
[主播] 我还我之前还给大家讲过，就是我以前去这个。
[主播] 阳谷县那次演讲。
[主播] 因为都是公益演讲，我们的演讲都是免费的嘛。
[主播] 然后呢，讲完之后呢，那个学校校长就很感谢，给我提了几几包当地那个烧鸡。
[主播] 因为大家知道河南道口有烧鸡。
[主播] 然后山东的德州有烧鸡，对吧？
[主播] 他们叫德州扒鸡。
[主播] 其实叫。
[主播] 然后呢，完了之后那个校长就给我买了个他们当地的这个烧鸡。
[主播] 说很好吃。
[主播] 我尝了一下，确实好吃。
[主播] 就一大桌子菜，每盘都很大。
[主播] 然后他们就极其的热情，热情到我天，你还没坐下，你又给你加菜，你刚坐下又给你这个倒水敬酒那种感觉。
[主播] 热情到人简直不想离开了。
[主播] 就跟爷爷奶奶对你那种爱一样。
[主播] 总觉得你饿没吃饱。
[主播] 营菜。
[主播] 然后呢，这个拿那烧鸡撕开，我们在这吃。
[主播] 特别香。
[主播] 然后就走的时候呢，还一共买了好几个，买了五个好像是。
[主播] 一个人一份。
[主播] 但是因为那天跟我后来还去另外一个我们小伙伴，那个小伙伴因为那个校长不知道来，他就没买到那个人的。
[主播] 然后我走的时候，我就把我手里的那份烧鸡送给了我那个小伙伴。
[主播] 因为他也忙前忙后嘛，对吧？
[主播] 我想让他感觉到他很重要，每个人都关注他。
[主播] 所以我就把我那份那份偷偷塞给了他。
[主播] 然后呢，大家没注意。
[主播] 结果那个校长就真的，就是你看山东人很豪爽，对吧？
[主播] 但豪爽的同时又很细腻。
[主播] 他很细腻的捕捉到了，哎呀，董老师走的时候手上没提我那个烧鸡的袋子。
[主播] 他就去问了一桌人，他说为什么董老师没有提烧鸡袋子呢？
[主播] 然后大家就说这个，因为董老师把他那个烧鸡给了这个朋友了。
[主播] 他说那董老师没有烧鸡是吧？
[主播] 他说啊。
[主播] 然后呢，我从这个山东阳谷县出来，坐车在石家庄好像哪周转。
[主播] 之后去了河南的新乡，好像是去的信乡，也去演讲了。
[主播] 去新乡也去演讲了。
[主播] 我在河南演讲完才回的这个当时的西安。
[主播] 等我到西安家里，我弟说，哥你为什么买这么多烧鸡？
[主播] 我说我啥时候买？
[主播] 有的一箱子呀。
[主播] 然后我就好奇，我说谁给我寄的？
[主播] 因为以前上学的时候，学生有时候偷偷给你送一点点小小卡片呀，自己折的小纸条那种。
[主播] 我说这一箱子烧鸡。
[主播] 我不知道。
[主播] 然后我就问他。
[主播] 最后过了几天那个校长才跟我说是他寄的。
[主播] 哎呀，感动了呀。
[主播] 都不好意思。
[主播] 拿人那么多。
[主播] 你跟人讲讲一次讲了个啥嘛。
[主播] 胡说八道了一个多小时。
[主播] 然后人给你寄一箱子烧鸡。
[主播] 然后后来我就把我朋友们全部叫到我家里分享。
[主播] 这种好东西不能自己吃。
[主播] 一起吃。
[主播] 是真的好。
[主播] 朋友说你看董宇辉这句话都说了好几遍了。
[主播] 这种事情是忍不住的，大家能理解吗？
[主播] 就是你再说多次，你都觉得你表达不清楚，你对别人那份心里的那个真诚的感动。
[主播] 平凡的人给我最多感动。
[主播] 所以你看，就是因为比如说南方城市我确实去得少。
[主播] 我当然我也去武汉啊，去过长沙啊，去过好多次。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 福州我去过，福州我去过三四次。
[主播] 去过南方很多城市。
[主播] 然后长江沿岸的我也去过，当然福州不是长江沿岸，长江沿岸的城市我也去过很多次。
[主播] 但是因为我可能大部分的时间活动在北方。
[主播] 就感觉到人们那种豪爽大方，然后又微微带一些细腻和善良。
[主播] 我的天哪。
[主播] 感动。
[主播] 我一见到这些人我就感动。
[主播] 抱住不舍得走那种感觉。
[主播] 所以为什么就是对这片土地爱的深沉呢？
[主播] 你真的得带着孩子多走一走。
[主播] 沿着黄河走一圈，沿着长江走一圈。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 最好有一个特别长的那种时间。
[主播] 你要是有暑假，那正好，把你那些年没休的假全部休，等孩子暑假走一圈。
[主播] 或者沿着在11的时候，沿着四处之路走过去。
[主播] 不用赶那些景点。
[主播] 赶那些景点没用，我跟你说。
[主播] 景点看都差不多。
[主播] 然后呢，走到哪吃到哪。
[主播] 然后呢，这个找的一些当地的人们喜欢吃的那些饭。
[主播] 感受一下风土人情，与当地人交谈。
[主播] 我其实印象特别深刻的是什么？
[主播] 有一年我们开车走这个四处，我卖书，卖书啊。
[主播] 大家自己买书。
[主播] 你看我讲的全部都是这个国家的城市，地方以及风土人情啊。
[主播] 我我确实在卖货。
[主播] 大家别骂了，别骂了。
[嘉宾] 枸杞。
[嘉宾] 蓝莓原浆还有吗？
[主播] 有。
[主播] 蓝莓原浆还有啊，想要的朋友自己去拍啊，这个是东方甄选自己的蓝莓原浆。
[主播] 东方甄选自己做的枸杞。
[主播] 你看我们在给做蓝莓原浆的时候，希望你感受到《鄂尔古纳河右岸》那本书里头的快乐。
[主播] 我还把驯鹿印在了盒子上。
[主播] 这就是我们设计的心思。
[主播] 然后你看设计枸杞的时候，我们想到的是什么呢？
[主播] 除了枸杞，我们给它弄了一个鹤。
[主播] 你看。
[主播] 鹤在中国的文化里头是一种非常美好的象征。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 延年益寿的那种那种象征啊，我说是鹤啊。
[主播] 不是功效，不是功效。
[主播] 我说是鹤的这种文化象征。
[主播] 它是文化。
[主播] 这个是事实啊。
[主播] 我们希望给食物美好的感觉。
[主播] 我们希望给这片土地厚重的体验。
[主播] 我们希望给这些长江河流以及沿岸的人们一些温情的故事。
[主播] 这样你就会由衷的热爱这片土地，当你热爱这片土地，热爱这些河流，热爱这些农产品。热爱土地上的每一个人，每一座城市，每一场烟火的时候。
[主播] 你对人，陌生人，哪怕是自卫魔。
[主播] 热爱这些河流，热爱这些农产品，热爱土地上的每一个人，每一座城市，每一场烟火的时候，
[主播] 你对人陌生人，哪怕是素位谋面的陌生人，你也会变得
[主播] 很善良。
[主播] 你也不怎么去攻击羞辱讽刺贬低他，因为你发现他在现实生活中看到人都挺和爱的。
[主播] 一到了网上，我的天哪，
[主播] 你都不是你了，你发现没？
[主播] 胡说八道，而且口出狂言，经常的对人这个挖苦讽刺，
[主播] 极尽羞辱。
[主播] 就为什么呢？生活中你是一个如此有教养的人，一到网上你就放飞自我。
[主播] 那都不叫放飞自我，那都是自己没有要求。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 所以，我觉得读这些书，让孩子去感受这些。
[主播] 我给大家讲，有一年我们不是，我刚喝的是哪一瓶？
[主播] 这个是吧？
[主播] 好，我有一年我们去自驾走丝绸之路啊。
[主播] 然后呢，
[主播] 应该是从敦煌，不是，酒泉。
[主播] 从酒泉过来的时候，我们从高速上给开开错了。
[主播] 就看到一个很小的乡镇的道路上，一路歪歪扭扭，歪歪扭扭开。
[主播] 开到半夜实在困得不行了，找到了一个村子。
[主播] 那其实是一个村子。
[主播] 但是应该是每年十一的时候到那去旅行，那个村子人就给给那开了个什么，给那开了一个那人就早上起来门口有卖个早餐的，卖个葡萄的，卖个瓜的，因为都已经十月了，所以我再想他们的葡萄和瓜应该都是当地人可能地里头剩下的，但是特别甜，而且那早甜的气人。
[主播] 然后呢，有一个特别简单的这个农家的这个旅馆，在里头睡了一晚上。
[主播] 第二天一大早，天特别冷，早上很冷嘛，十一，当时已经很冷了，在这个河西走廊。
[主播] 机场的雾度。
[主播] 然后休息了一晚上呢，发现恢复了体力，头脑清醒，但是空气清冷，然后机场的雾度。
[主播] 然后就走到这个旁边的
[主播] 走到旁边的一个不起眼的小餐馆里头，特别小破的牌子。
[主播] 里头就简单的几张桌椅。
[主播] 然后呢，老板很热情，问你吃什么？我说你们这有什么？羊肉汤，我说那就来份羊肉汤。
[主播] 羊杂汤。
[主播] 哎呀，那个羊杂汤煮的那个汤白白的，真香。
[主播] 然后完了之后就已经要了俩饼，烧饼应该是，煮了一碗羊杂汤，要了一碗烧饼。
[主播] 连吃带喝，那一早那个早餐，哎呀，我到现在都怀念那一口。
[主播] 我也不知道是那个地方让我喜欢，还是那碗羊杂汤煮的真好，还是说当时真的饿。
[主播] 总之就极其印象深刻。
[主播] 我们后来从那儿就开到了哪儿？开到了银川去了，也不知道咋胡开的。
[主播] 绕到了银川。
[主播] 绕到银川的时候，当时就买了很多的狗起。
[主播] 买了那个，这个银川那个时候有那个枣，十一的时候有一种黑色的，黑红黑红的枣，硬邦邦的，但是特别甜，吃就是阳光的味道。
[主播] 我在银川停了一天。
[主播] 我以前有一个在西安新东方的时候有一个同事，因为西安近年雾霾比较重。
[主播] 他为了让孩子的成长体验好些。
[主播] 他放弃了西安那些东西，跑的银川去了。
[主播] 真的。
[主播] 然后他就经常在我们以前的群里头发，到了冬天孩子在河床的那个啥上，那冰上跑来跑去。
[主播] 然后他得知那天晚上我去了，要请我吃饭，但我没叫特别晚特别晚了，已经饭店可能都关门了吧。
[主播] 第二天一大早，他过来给我送了一袋子东西。
[主播] 我还睡的迷迷糊糊的，东西过来一放，他开车又走了。
[主播] 没有多多谈。
[主播] 我把那一包袋子一直放车后备箱，我跟几个，我其实坐朋友的车，不是我的车，那会我还没有车，坐朋友的车。
[主播] 然后到家了我才把那个袋子打开，里头放了五包枣，放了四四包这个
[主播] 呃，就是这个狗起。
[主播] 我的天哪，特别感动。
[主播] 一大早风尘不服的还给你一送。
[主播] 扭头就走。
[主播] 就是你发现赤诚的人，不管在哪一片土地上，他都极其的赤诚。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 枣，狗起。
[主播] 晒透的阳光，风干之后仍然露出一种迷人的红色。
[主播] 像极了我们对亲人的祝福，像极了我们对朋友的爱惜，像极了我们对生活的期待，也像极了我们对家人的嘱托。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 你要说狗起，那宁夏中卫的狗起谁不知道这好？
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 然后呢，而且我们选的是头茶，头茶是什么意思？就是从每年五月底六月初开始，到基本上到就九月末嘛，十月初那茶已经受不了了，温度太低了。
[主播] 他一年会收好多茶，好多茶。
[主播] 但是收的后面那些茶，因为可能养分啊什么就不太够了。
[主播] 你像能十月，他就不结了，十一月，十二月，一月，二月，三月，四月，五月，经过半年的休养生息，从那个细腻的黄河肥沃土壤中汲取的营养，在五月初，五月末六月初长出的头一茶。
[主播] 这就是。
[主播] 有红色的盒子，也有绿色的盒子啊。
[主播] 泡好了一杯。
[主播] 先放著啊。
[主播] 我我清个嗓子，不好意思啊。
[主播] 这个杯子不影响，我一个人，杯子应该是洗干净的杯子，看。
[嘉宾] 对，它那个杯子就是那个颜色。
[主播] 对，这是这个，这个叫什么灰色？
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 然后呢，当然也给大家注意。
[主播] 这个虽然我们经常喜欢那种，比如说你看泡好的狗起，红色的，对吧？
[主播] 饱满的。
[主播] 然后呢，鲜艳的颜色泡在水里，我们觉得肯定是集合了很多美好与祝福。
[主播] 很多的营养和元素在里头。
[主播] 但实际上最后大家泡完还是要把它吃掉，因为主要的营养还是在狗起里，泡水呢，
[主播] 大部分的营养其实无法溶解于水的。
[主播] 还得吃掉。
[主播] 就比如说大家煮鸡汤，煮排骨汤，你到最后你还是得把它吃了。
[主播] 我说到这，导演突然看了看自己泡了一早上的狗起。
[主播] 还是得吃。
[主播] 给。
[主播] 再给你加一包。
[主播] 女孩子可以多用一些这个。
[主播] 给。
[主播] 给你泡一包。
[主播] 泡了之后还是要吃呢。
[主播] 可以直接吃，可以直接当瓜子去磕的一样，啊。
[主播] 当然它不需要没有没有那个壳啊。
[主播] 直接这样吃就行。
[主播] 然后咱前天不是给大家推荐过银耳吗？
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 对吧？弄银耳手泡。
[嘉宾] 会员干。
[主播] 会员啊。
[嘉宾] 我就泡个狗起。
[主播] 狗起放一块泡。
[主播] 我给大家推荐一个特别好的吃法啊。
[主播] 去过宁夏的，去过甘肃的。
[主播] 朋友大家一定知道一个茶叫什么？
[主播] 叫八宝茶。
[主播] 或者叫三泡台好像叫。
[嘉宾] 三泡台我听过。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 你知道我在2020年暑假。
[主播] 我在2020年暑假。
[主播] 当上课了。
[主播] 我平常是一个
[主播] 西北走的人。
[主播] 而且千万不能一个人去，一个人去没意思。
[主播] 重要的从来不是目的地，而是沿途的风景和与你同行的人啊。
[主播] 当时就问我那些老师。
[主播] 谁想去？
[主播] 一块去，开了两个车。
[主播] 从西安出发。
[主播] 经过了
[主播] 哪？
[主播] 经过了兰州。
[主播] 然后停在了临夏。
[主播] 大家知道临夏不？
[主播] 临夏是一个
[主播] 临夏。
[主播] 不是宁夏，是临夏。
[主播] 没听过吧？
[嘉宾] 没有。
[主播] 哎呀，那地方。
[主播] 我们去的时候当时刮著大风下著雨，那雨里头，因为那块下雨都是泥点子嘛。
[主播] 当时很很著急的就住在酒店里了。
[主播] 等第二天早上太阳出来了。
[主播] 很好看。
[主播] 哎，我有一个学生就是临夏的，那孩子经过一段时间的努力，后来考上了兰州大学。
[主播] 很开心的孩子。
[主播] 然后孩子后来跟我发过临下很多那种湖。
[嘉宾] 这个湖。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 然后我都没去过，我我但是我我在临夏吃了一顿特别经典的，特别经典的手抓羊。
[主播] 哎呀，好。
[主播] 手抓羊。
[主播] 哎呀，好吃到气人。
[主播] 这就是你看。
[主播] 你带孩子去体验，读这些书，然后让他满满的期待的时候，然后再去那些地方。
[主播] 刘家峡是，对。
[主播] 刘家峡离那不远。
[主播] 是州啊，不是区。
[主播] 甘肃临夏。
[主播] 然后，我就我就记得这个停到一个饭馆里。
[主播] 在一个一个一个大厅里，很热闹，没桌子都是人。
[主播] 然后上来那个手抓羊肉。
[主播] 我跟人要些生蒜，哎呀，一口肉一口蒜，哎呀。
[主播] 吃到差不多时候，人上来一个一个大碗，啊。
[主播] 完了以后是什么呢？黄冰糖。
[主播] 注意，人不用普通冰糖，人是黄冰糖。
[主播] 大枣。
[主播] 狗起。
[主播] 芝麻。
[主播] 应该还有核桃我记得。
[主播] 然后再就是那个绿茶。
[主播] 泡，一直泡，一直喝，一直泡，一直喝。
[主播] 人可以给你加料，也可以给你加水，你一直喝。
[主播] 你像这个吃的自己很满足，然后边聊天边喝，哎呀，那一天真是太快乐了。
[主播] 可以无限喝下去。
[主播] 好像当地人把那个叫什么？
[主播] 有朋友说没有核桃是吧？
[主播] 叫盖碗茶是吧？
[主播] 还有桂圆，对。
[嘉宾] 桂圆。
[嘉宾] 你手边那个就是桂圆。
[主播] 桂圆。
[主播] 这是桂圆干啊，大家买回去之后试著泡一下。
[主播] 我们这有狗起，有桂圆，咱有枣没？
[主播] 昨天我记得有那个枣，把那个枣拿来快。
[主播] 让大家尝试，这个直接都是桂圆干的，把核子去掉的，你看。
[嘉宾] 你泡的。
[主播] 看，直接就是桂圆干，让我给我杯子里放进去。
[主播] 咱昨天有那个枣没？
[主播] 就是大包的那个枣。
[主播] 这个枣，枣圈也行。
[主播] 我不是有一个好吃什么，啥啥好那个。
[嘉宾] 好想你。
[主播] 好想你是吧？
[主播] 没点事。
[主播] 枣。
[主播] 狗起。
[主播] 桂圆。
[主播] 黄冰糖现在有吗？
[嘉宾] 没有。
[主播] 黄冰糖现在没有了是吧？
[主播] 没有了算了。
[主播] 茶叶今天也没有是吧？
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 你自己家里有的话你弄啊。
[主播] 往一块一泡，哎呀。
[主播] 太享受了。
[主播] 我对这片土地爱的深沉啊。
[主播] 我们后来一路开过去，只要沿路看到一饭点就停。
[主播] 就点一个手抓肉。
[主播] 真香。
[主播] 来，朋友想要自己去拍啊。
[主播] 有朋友说有。
[嘉宾] 狗起只有四百单了。
[主播] 有朋友说那个也有人把那个叫罐罐茶是吧？
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 对，你知道人泡那个茶里头的枣是烤过的吧？
[主播] 不知道吧？
[主播] 他们弄的那个枣是用火烤过的。
[主播] 所以才有特殊的味道。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 有朋友说有罐罐茶不一样是吧？
[主播] 有罐罐茶好像就是煮的，对，就是有的是用一个小罐，然后放到火上一直烧著煮。
[主播] 其实材料大部分是相似的。
[主播] 只不过是加工的方法不一样，有的是一直泡著，直接用碗里头热水加进泡。
[主播] 有的人放上面咕嘟咕嘟咕嘟煮一下。
[主播] 煮的那个枣必须得烧。
[主播] 必须得烧。
[主播] 不烧你没有味。
[主播] 跟你说。
[主播] 烧到外表有点焦糊，美拉德反应嘛。
[主播] 哎呀，泡出来那个那个茶水是真香。
[主播] 主要其实就是为了那口味道的。
[主播] 所以你看这就是我们的饮食文化呀。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 会从各种丰富而精致的食材中，或许那丝微微的甜，微微的苦和微微的酸混合在一起。
[主播] 还有黄冰糖。
[主播] 太棒了。
[主播] 九曲黄河呀。
[主播] 自己买啊。
[主播] 这个书可以都买一些，吃的你看你自己。
[主播] 书可以家里带著自己的孩子一块看。
[主播] 有朋友说我，昨天我看到有一个朋友在我，我在我们视频下面评论说，我现在还在备孕。
[主播] 但是我已经给把孩子孩子把书都准备著了。
[主播] 这未雨绸缪。
[主播] 这是真的。
[主播] 提前计划，有远见呢。
[主播] 买的有点过于早了。
[主播] 但是你可以先翻啊。
[主播] 对不对？你看完之后你再以后给孩子讲什么了？
[嘉宾] 这个哥哥。
[主播] 我觉得这是有道理的，你觉得呢？
[嘉宾] 我觉得容易太焦虑。
[主播] 那不是焦虑，是分享。
[主播] 是让孩子，这也不是说孩子什么什么吧，考试题那种。
[主播] 这是一种喜悦呀。
[主播] 分享的喜悦。
[主播] 你看我们现在给大家推荐的这些东西喝的多么健康。
[主播] 大兴安岭林区的，清晨挂著露珠的，裹著白霜的野生蓝莓原浆哦。
[主播] 是吧？
[主播] 而且这个就那个证明来，我给大家展示一下。
[主播] 而且这个蓝莓可不是普通蓝莓。
[主播] 这个蓝莓是什么蓝莓？这个蓝莓是
[主播] 不行，我得把报告拿出来，不然我说了会扣分的啊。
[主播] 来大家看一下。
[主播] 抖音是很
[主播] 很严格的，我觉得这个严格是好事，在食品方面严格是好事。
[主播] 要不然我如果没有这个标识，我这胡说八道，万一是骗你的，对吧？
[主播] 人品不可靠的其实。
[主播] 人靠不住。
[主播] 但是这些检测报告靠得住。
[主播] 野生采摘的有机蓝莓。
[主播] 那所以很多屏幕前，比如说 for the pregnant,准妈妈们，孩子和老人和放心。
[主播] 蓝莓。
[主播] 然后呢，当然你如果想喝了，你还可以用狗起，这个脆枣圈。
[主播] 呃，这个这个叫东西叫什么？桂圆干。
[主播] 它是把核去掉了。
[嘉宾] 核也去掉的。
[主播] 直接就是桂圆肉啊。
[嘉宾] 对啊。
[主播] 可以直接吃。
[主播] 当个小甜点吃。
[主播] 你看。
[主播] 看。
[主播] 特别好吃。
[主播] 有朋友说，人靠不住。
[嘉宾] 东西会确实靠不住。
[主播] 我感到很多时候，特别需要我的时刻，很多时候我都不在。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 所以我说我自己靠不住。
[主播] 想的朋友自己拍了啊。
[主播] 有朋友说我把这个展示一下啊。
[主播] 看一下这里头。
[主播] 我得把这个挪开了。
[主播] 很完整的给大家展示一下。
[主播] 它从长江的发源，途经的城市，然后以及路上流过的城市边缘有哪些水力工程。
[主播] 古建筑。
[主播] 对应的野生动物。
[主播] 地形变化。
[主播] 甚至我们修的水电站。
[主播] 非常完整啊。
[主播] 这套书呢，不仅孩子能看，其实很多平常看书少的朋友，你自己在家里也可以看。
[主播] 但是我给大家更多的建议是什么？是看完了这些书之后，其实你的知识量够不够丰富？
[主播] 其实不够丰富。
[主播] 看完了书之后应该更多去看什么？
[主播] 纪录片。
[主播] 啊，掌握大量的这个事实性的信息和知识之后，然后有机会带孩子去走一圈。
[主播] 读万卷书，行万里路呀。
[主播] 得行啊。
[主播] 来，我们下继续给大家推荐新的产品啊。
[主播] 有朋友说把我挂小黄车。
[主播] 能挂吗？
[嘉宾] 有一个你的T恤。
[主播] 有一个我的T恤。
[主播] 我怕是挂不了的。
[主播] 我们家只有三个孩子。
[主播] 把我挂了妈妈会难过的。
[主播] 把我挂了这谁拉磨呀？
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 有我的T恤给大家谈一下。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 刚拍的狗起其实是可以和这个乌鸡炖汤的。
[嘉宾] 桂圆可以炖汤吗？
[嘉宾] 可以。
[主播] 我不知道，反正我我之前那次回家给我妈妈炖这个汤，我放的狗起。
[主播] 妈妈很开心。
[主播] 哎，那个我还没喝完呢。
[主播] 那个是我刚喝的吗？
[嘉宾] 不知道。
[主播] 有一瓶我没喝完的。
[嘉宾] 没事。
[主播] 不不不，你把那拿出来，我把它喝了，放里头就坏了。
[嘉宾] 对，你刚盖盖的那个是吧？
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 狗起。
[主播] 泡到杯子去。
[主播] 来。
[主播] 乌鸡啊。
[主播] 白石轩的乌鸡。
[主播] 然后赠大家这个菌菇的料包。
[主播] 然后你刚买了狗起，搭配在一起就行了。
[主播] 有朋友说桂圆可以炖汤了。
[主播] 哦。
[主播] 看来大家都有很生活的经验啊。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 好茶。
[主播] 咱刚才卖的烤肠吗？
[嘉宾] 是一根。
[主播] 哇。
[主播] 哎哟。
[主播] 管吃管住呀，这公司。
[主播] 我终于实现了我妈妈跟我说的工作的期待。
[主播] 以前在新方当老师，从来没有节假日。
[主播] 妈妈说你能不能找一个正经工，正式工作。
[主播] 节假日都不稳定。
[主播] 转行中卖菜。
[主播] 都不要正式工作，你找个正经工作。
[主播] 我妈对好工作理解就是管吃管住。
[主播] 包吃包住一个月五千。
[主播] 多好呀。
[嘉宾] 现在是实现了。
[主播] 现在包吃了。
[主播] 下一步我把房租一退，往公司一睡。
[主播] 早上起来卫生间洗个澡。
[主播] 包吃包住。
[主播] 实现了。
[嘉宾] 嘴巴上是茶叶。
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 嘴巴上有油是吧？
[主播] 不好意思，不好意思。
[主播] 失礼了啊。
[主播] 哎哟，你看这肉汁，没注意的。
[主播] 只要你找一个工作，其实多钱和干啥，很难吸引我妈妈。
[主播] 但你只要是包吃包住，我的天哪，都衣食无忧了。
[主播] 乌鸡啊。
[主播] 不好意思，我咽一下，要不然这样对大家不尊重。
[主播] 来。
[主播] 乌鸡啊。
[主播] 乌鸡，89块钱买一送一，然后再送大家一包这个九味的菌汤包。
[主播] 云南的朋友一听到君子，君子，云南人说的是君子。
[主播] 四声，君子。
[嘉宾] 贵州也是说的君子。
[主播] 贵州也是说的君子，你不是想人，你咋说贵州说是君子？
[嘉宾] 朋友是贵州。
[主播] 四川也有地方是君子。一听都DNA都动了，我的天哪。
[主播] 忍不住。
[主播] 一天往医院跑两趟，回来那锅君子还是舍不得倒，还是得吃。
[嘉宾] 炖汤喝。
[主播] 但是好像我印象中大家都喜欢。对，炖汤，炖那个汤呢，它那个肉烂得特别快。它跟普通鸡肉不一样，它那个肉烂得特别快，而且那个汤可以炖出白色嘛。
[主播] 我第一次看到那个新闻的时候，都笑，笑死我了。
[主播] 喝着真的很香。
[主播] 我说，怎么会有这么可爱的人呢？就是他就是舍不得那口鲜。
[主播] 然后呢，就把那个带了回去，一只送给了妈妈，一只送给了奶奶。
[主播] 你觉得真的，他们说君子煮好了比肉都好吃。
[主播] 喜欢吃啊。
[主播] 妈妈居然说，以后别买这些东西。
[主播] 吃完了之后呢，发现有点头晕。
[主播] 眼睛前面冒星星，抱着门开始说话。
[主播] 炖好之后，赶紧给隔壁的阿姨们每人分享一份，这是我儿子给我买的。
[主播] 就跟董宇辉当年那次去丽江，我朋友他哥开了一个那个猪脚酸菜，猪脚火锅。
[主播] 懂我的意思吗？
[主播] 好可爱啊，他们，是吧？
[主播] 来，接下来给大家带来一个。
[主播] 那打一缸，锅里的那个大麦酒。
[主播] 董宇辉甄选转型。
[主播] 一样。
[主播] 我跟几个朋友一晚上把那个人炫完了。
[主播] 现在叫七个月之后给大家带来一款惊喜啊。
[主播] 炫完之后，
[嘉宾] 我们二号链接也有一个黑胡椒的调料。
[主播] 6月9号的早上，突然有1万人涌入这个直播间里听我胡说八道，听我天气行星，大江大河，三川四季，直短情长。
[主播] 喝醉了。
[主播] 二号链接有黑胡椒调料。
[主播] 当时你回休息啊。
[主播] 如果想让这个肉汁的香更好。
[主播] 妈没事，妈没事。最后我那个朋友他哥哥晚上饭店要关门了，董宇辉抱着门硬是不走。抱着门说话聊天，你听我说。我给你说，表达欲望特别强烈。话多呀。君子好吃。然后呢，加上这个乌鸡，炖个汤。夏天了，大家就其实可以多吃一些这些。你看我们传统饮食文化里都鼓励大家夏天吃羊嘛，对吧？因为羊是羊肉是一种，我不能说，因为再说就是属于食物功效了啊。大家喜欢的话，自己去拍。89块9，买一送一，两只鸡啊，很便宜了。然后还送你一包这个料呢。菌汤包。这里头有红枣、杏鲍菇、蛹虫草、茶树菇、枸杞、姬油菌、鹿茸菇、羊肚菌、鸡松茸。我印象特别早的是，我哪一年回家？有一年回家的时候，你看，这好多年前了，说起来都惭愧啊。要脸说。当时回家，然后好像当时是母亲节还是妈妈生日，我记不太清楚了。我买，我平常每次回去就是给爷爷奶奶、爸爸妈妈买一大堆的，比如说这个鱼啊、爷爷喜欢吃的鸡蛋糕啊、奶粉啊那些，买一大堆。再买一些水果，每次我都是几乎买一样的东西，冰箱给他们塞满，然后我就走了。我以前在西安工作的时候，保证自己一个月回去一次。还是谁能力大，谁给老人多买嘛。然后呢，那次买完之后，走路上呢，突然想起来。好像是，好像是母亲节，我忘了。还是妇女节，还是母亲节，还是我妈生日，反正就是这三个日子中的某一个。突然想，不行不行不行，转过头回去买了两只乌鸡。其实我也不知道它喝了有啥用。
[主播] 当时我就是拿着一口锅，卖着牛排。然后呢，当然我们也自己一直在做牛排，当时其实牛排已经进入了一个最终在敲定的阶段了。我们从原材料上选得很仔细。因为大家知道现在大量的牛排，好点品质的，价格合适一些牛排，其实要靠进口的。但是不同国家对于牛的这个饲料里头能不能加动物蛋白，以及他们允不允许加一些添加剂，或者一些其他的的东西。各个国家是不一样的，包括了大家知道关于牛肉的品质和牛的一些常见疾病的，不同国家他们现在的情况和要求也不一样的。所以经过综合的选择呢，我们选择了这一款。而且它也是经典的安格斯牛的品种，世界四大名牛。安格斯牛的一个优点是什么？就是大家看这。谷饲之后呢，牛的脂肪会分，会分散在肉的肌理里头。所以这样大家放了平底锅以后煎一下，温度在五六十度的时候，这个脂肪就会开始融化。然后呢，正着这样放进去，先煎煎煎，煎到你感觉边上有血水渗出来，那个其实是肌红蛋白很正常啊。然后呢，再这样斜着，再煎，煎一煎这边也有这个渗出来了，然后再翻过来，煎到下面看出来已经这种焦黄色的，再翻过来再煎。大概就是这个样子。就是我们大家平常所说的七分熟。因为这个牛排比较厚，可以啊。注意厚的才叫牛排，薄的叫牛肉片，一百多块钱几十片呢，那叫牛肉片啊。当然风俭由人，都行，都行啊，都行。然后呢，另外一个这个是原切。原切的一个特点是什么？就是它没有添加，多少肉它就切出来多少牛排。甚至边角料和外面的脂肪去掉，其实是少的。也有其他的味道的调和的，或者是其他的各种方式的牛排。我我说了风俭由人啊，看大家自己消费习惯。但是建议如果是给家里的老人和孩子吃的话，建议吃原切的。OK，原切的，因为它里头没有加其他的东西。就是多少斤肉就是切出来多少斤牛排。它相对会更加安全一些。当然我任何食品里头现在的添加，如果是合法范围内的，符合国家食品安全标准的，它应该也都是经过仔细考虑的啊。我只不过是我自己个人担忧而已啊，可能是我多虑了。然后这个牛排刚才给大家展示了，你看，首先它的品质特别好。整个这个肥瘦相间的这种感觉，大理石的花纹叫marbling。然后还有一个点就是什么？在煎的时候，这个肉汁会融化，融化之后呢，你切开之后吃的时候有一种特别好的味道。安格斯牛，它的这个脂肪融化了之后是一种淡淡的奶香味，这是属于安格斯牛一个特殊的风味吧。跟牛的品种和饲料其实有非常大的关系。我们再什么时候会吃牛排？其实很多时候都是大家去一些比较高档的餐厅，对吧，西餐厅。谈恋爱的时候是带着自己的男女朋友去吃。然后呢，成家立业有了孩子之后，更多的时候，孩子喜欢吃这种新奇的食物。偶尔给他改变一次，原来跟原来不一样的伙食，孩子兴奋好几天。昨天晚上我跟石明在讲这个牛排的时候，我突然说了一段话，我说，其实更建议把牛排买回去之后，花一个时间给爸爸妈妈煎一次。因为这个安格斯牛它的特点是150天谷饲，它其实肉是很嫩的。但是跟你做的方，法确实有很大关系，你不能说把那个做完煎的全熟，那帮硬。那肯定就老了，什么牛排煎到全熟其实都有点硬了。这样先煎，看到血水，再这样煎，再出血水，再翻过来煎，煎到这个焦黄色，再这样翻，煎的焦黄色就好了。煎的过程中呢，你撒一些这个黑胡椒颗粒和盐就行了。当然你也可以拿那种小的番茄，中间切开，放在锅旁边煎一下。
[主播] 给旁边画一块黄油。注意黄油不是用来直接煎牛排的。因为黄油的味道太重了，就把牛肉的好味就盖住了，能理解吧？你如果买的牛排很普通，你可以用，但是稍微好点牛排你其实不要那样做。你把牛肉本身的好味就盖住了。你发现当一般都是斜着，把那一块黄油在旁边化开。然后用勺子或者这个叉子把那个往上面淋。为啥？它只是想让你牛上面有一点点黄油的香味就行了。煎好之后出来是不是立刻就可以切了呀？
[嘉宾] 不是。要醒肉。
[主播] 非常好，要稍微放一下，要醒一下。
[主播] 你看，醒酒一样，醒肉。
[主播] 醒，醒一下，然后这时候再去切切切切切开。
[主播] 放好一个叉子。
[主播] 我觉得给爱的人准备一次特别好的这种餐饭，其实非常充满仪式感。
[主播] 我小时候给大家，我之前给大家描述过，我小时候家里吃的很多种特别有意思的饭。
[主播] 比如说妈妈准备过年的时候做的那种年菜，北方人很多地方都炖呢，对吧，东北也炖的那种。
[主播] 前羊炖不炖？
[嘉宾] 炖。
[主播] 就是它有这个煮，煮过猪排骨的汤。
[主播] 有做的这个肉，还有丸子。
[主播] 还有那个黄花菜、海带片、炸的红薯块、粉条。
[主播] 对对对，有各种各样的东西。你们有那个菜吗？
[嘉宾] 烩菜我们。
[主播] 烩菜，差不多吧。
[主播] 就特别香，香到气人，我的天哪。
[主播] 然后呢，比如说生病的时候，姐姐耐心给你煮那个红豆沙里头煮的汤圆。
[主播] 比如说过年的时候，爸爸给你炖的那个，果园里挖出来的山药和那个排骨汤。
[主播] 就是小时候我们的很多的美食的回忆，都是家人花的心思，熬了很长时间准备的那一餐饭，对吧？
[主播] 味道特别好，很精致。
[主播] 那现在呢，你也可以抽一个时间周末，当然你给孩子做很正常，给你自己做很正常。
[主播] 我也建议你能抽一个时间给自己的爸妈煎一次牛排，让他们也感受一下，对吧，你的心意。
[主播] 其实你觉得一片牛排有什么特殊的？没有。
[主播] 你要说买特别好品质牛排，我们这个反而还不建议呢。
[主播] 有的朋友如果吃的特别高端的话，他肯定吃的是特别贵的牛排，那一块可能就好几百了。
[主播] 我们这个就只能说相对相同品质里头，性价比做的很好的。
[主播] 安格斯150天谷饲，如果懂的朋友就知道这个。
[主播] 当然你得真的是安格斯。
[主播] 是真是假，朋友是能吃出来的啊。
[主播] 有朋友说上楠楠。
[主播] 为什么要楠楠呢？
[主播] 楠楠今天不在啊。
[主播] 楠楠在吗？
[嘉宾] 应该是晚场。
[主播] 晚场。
[主播] 我姐也叫楠楠啊。
[主播] 我感谢大家。
[主播] 其实很多时候大家是出于这个好心。
[主播] 董宇辉都29岁了。
[主播] 还整。
[主播] 昨天晚上大家听完石明给我黑的黑料之后，大家都震惊了。
[主播] 董宇辉没想到你起了个大早，赶了个晚集啊。
[主播] 初三就开始尝试给别人写情书。
[主播] 搞到了现在还是个这个。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 生活难以自理。
[主播] 大家关心我，所以呢，总是找了替我找对象。
[主播] 看到我们公司哪个女同事都想给我找对象。
[主播] 但是他们做错了什么，要被你这样推到火坑里，对吧？
[主播] 自由恋爱，人有选择的权利。
[主播] 还有一个呢，我当然能理解大家的好心，但是我们有的女同事，比如人已经有了男朋友，已经有了家庭的这种，大家有的时候出于善意开的玩笑，其实反而可能起到一些不好的效果。
[主播] 你觉得呢？
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 那些不用说，没事，董宇辉自有他的福气呢。
[主播] 福气没到呢。
[主播] 你的夫妻在后头呢，就是那个意思。
[主播] 石明，你的福气在后头呢，大概就是那个意思。
[主播] 不用着急，没事。
[主播] 这两天很多人替我操心。
[主播] 你知道这两天已经开始跟我大量私信的人，从之前一些关注到我的同龄人。
[主播] 当时很多人就反馈，董宇辉，你竟然是93年的。
[主播] 你说你是93年的，我都震惊了。
[主播] 说你08年的时候初三，我，我初三08年也是初三啊。
[主播] 我现在孩子都四岁了，你怎么搞的？
[主播] 以前是这种。
[主播] 最近呢，很多人跟我私信，然后我会看，有的时候来不及回，但是我我会看。
[主播] 我害怕有的，比如说那种问问题啊，或者我们的售后问题啊，反馈的。
[主播] 然后其他的，不太重要的，比如说就是一些寒暄的，打招呼的，咱们也是嘛，我就看完我就不回复了，有的时候，回不完。
[主播] 然后呢，我发现最近几年开始跟我回复多的，已经私信多的已经成了什么了？都是妈妈们。
[主播] 董宇辉，你要好好吃饭。
[主播] 你要注意身体。
[主播] 我儿子跟你差不多大小，或者我女儿跟你差不多大小。
[主播] 工作是一方面。
[主播] 你还不是说了吗，对吧，人生长期拼体力。
[主播] 工作哪有一两天做成的？
[主播] 你好好吃饭，好好睡觉，要爱惜身体，你爸妈在意你做多大事吗？
[主播] 不，你爸妈在意的只是你是不是吃得好，睡得好。
[主播] 哎呀，真感动啊。
[主播] 真的，这是说的实话。
[主播] 我给大家讲苏东坡那个在黄州46岁，他那个儿子生下来，王昭君生了儿子，对吧？
[主播] 写，写什么？
[主播] 唯愿吾儿愚且鲁，无灾无难到公卿啊。
[主播] 傻一点，笨一点。
[主播] 对吧，快乐长大就行了。
[主播] 说世人扬，人皆养子望聪明。
[主播] 我为聪明，误一生啊。
[主播] 想让孩子聪明。
[主播] 你看我因为聪明，受多大的苦。
[主播] 苏东坡写的，唯愿吾儿愚且鲁，无灾无难到公卿啊。
[主播] 来，东方甄选的牛排，刚给大家讲了。
[主播] 乌拉圭安格斯牛种，150天谷饲。
[主播] 卖的牛都是公牛，而且都是阉割之后的公牛。
[主播] 哪有人拿母牛去做牛排呢？
[主播] 母牛是要育种的，朋友们。
[主播] 都是公牛。
[主播] 然后呢，在宰杀之前有150天的谷饲，吃的就是玉米和豆粕。
[主播] 为什么要吃那个呢？因为吃完之后，你看，它的肉里头就会有非常好的这个大理石的花纹了。
[主播] 然后大家在刚给你们讲好了怎么煎了，对吧？
[主播] 煎的时候呢，用橄榄油可以，或者家里头普通你做菜油，只要没有特别重的味道的那种油都可以啊。
[主播] 烟点高一点的都可以。
[主播] 然后煎的时候煎出这个渗出雪水，再翻过来，翻出雪水，再翻过来，然后焦黄色，再翻过去，每一面都煎两次，差不多就是七分熟。
[主播] 牛排记住就是中间带一点点红，就是或者说带一点点生的那种，其实就是七分熟了。
[主播] 全熟的可能就会有点硬。
[主播] 但是这个牛排我昨天试吃，吃了。
[主播] 是口感真的好。
[主播] 因为我自己大学的时候，我给大家讲过，在大学的时候，因为那会想要练英语嘛。
[主播] 交了一些外国朋友。
[主播] 大家心知肚明。
[主播] 互相练英语呢，其实。
[主播] 然后他们拿我练中文的，他们跟我说中文，我跟他们说英语。
[主播] 互相为难彼此。
[主播] 我也听不懂他们的中文，他们也听不懂我的英语。
[主播] 然后那会就跟他们吃了很多的牛排。
[主播] 吃得多了，就有时候是能吃出来一些的。
[主播] 包括后来出国吃的多了。
[主播] 确实能吃出来一些，然后这个牛排在这个价格里头算。
[主播] 很可以了。
[主播] 我们必须不能脱离品质谈价格，对吧，也不能脱离价格谈品质啊。
[主播] OK，想的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 299，然后六块。
[其他] 我90年，我儿子明年要高考了。
[主播] 你再别胡说，你90年。
[主播] 石明就是90年的。
[其他] 儿子明年高考。
[主播] 90年今年31岁。
[主播] 高考是18岁。
[主播] 胡说说什么？
[主播] 我也是有一点点智商的好吗？
[主播] 来，接下来给大家带来一个爆浆冰糖玉米。
[主播] 这个有煮好的吗？
[嘉宾] 可以生吃。
[嘉宾] 有有有。
[主播] 可以生吃？
[主播] 我，生吃真的吗？
[嘉宾] 可以生吃。
[主播] 我试试。
[主播] 我欠这上面动着冰霜。
[主播] 然后咋爆？
[主播] 当冰棍吃。
[主播] 这是哪产的？
[嘉宾] 厦门是吧？
[嘉宾] 厦门还是云南？
[主播] 我吃一口，不能把这个，哎呀，真个浪费了。
[嘉宾] 厦门。
[嘉宾] 这个玉米有奶味。
[嘉宾] 早上有吃，都可香了。
[主播] 哎，确实是甜的，确实有奶味，哈哈。
[主播] 以前记得有玉米，我也生着吃过。
[主播] 但是确实没有这个甜，也没有这个奶味重。
[嘉宾] 这个是冰糖玉米。
[主播] 冰糖玉米是吧？
[嘉宾] 有奶香味。
[主播] 很神奇。
[主播] 那可以煮熟了吃吧？
[嘉宾] 可以。
[嘉宾] 可以煮。
[嘉宾] 你看它盖上面有。
[主播] 营养美味，可生食的水果粗粮，一口爆汁，牛奶清香，甘蔗甜味。
[主播] 可以生食，也可以微波炉加热，也可以炖汤，也可以。
[主播] 神奇。
[主播] 哇，好甜哦。
[主播] 给，你们俩把这些分。
[嘉宾] 没有样品了。
[嘉宾] 我包一个尝尝。
[主播] 没事，你们俩把那个吃吧。
[主播] 留着，这个不允许再拆了，谁拆的？
[主播] 追打他。
[主播] 吃吧，吃吧，吃吧，没事，吃吧。
[嘉宾] 冻的。
[主播] 这附近超市能买到这个样品吗？
[嘉宾] 应该买不到。
[主播] 买不到是吧？
[嘉宾] 只有我们有。
[主播] 太可怜了，我给你们俩掰一点吧。
[嘉宾] 别别别。
[主播] 给。
[主播] 哇，你看这个一掰，你看，把这玉米，你看，真的，捏破了。
[主播] 流到手上，真的牛奶一样。
[主播] 吃吧，没事，你吃吧。
[主播] 家里以前种玉米，每年收玉米收有的那种玉米梗，长得小，或者阳光不足，它玉米棒子结得晚那种，就是特别嫩。
[主播] 我就记得当时奶奶就把它剥下放嘴里。
[主播] 嚼着，就是大概这个味道，但确实没有这么甜。
[主播] 这个奶味也没有这么重。
[嘉宾] 真的有奶味。
[主播] 大米过几天就有了啊。
[主播] 我们之前的那个大米，因为连四段小作文之后，大米卖空了。
[主播] 空了这么长时间都没有再补上。
[主播] 所以由此可见，火真的是个意外。
[主播] 都没有准备好。
[其他] 朋友说明明昨晚出过海参。
[主播] 我在这啃生玉米。
[嘉宾] 阿姨煮生蚝了。
[嘉宾] 生蚝。
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 阿姨煮生蚝了。
[主播] 阿姨煮生蚝了是吧？
[主播] 不羡慕了，生蚝就不羡慕了。
[其他] 朋友说想听课，好。
[主播] 把生蚝卖完讲课。
[嘉宾] 玉米只有四百单。
[主播] 哇，这么大的生蚝。
[主播] 这个玉米真的好好吃，你尝一下。
[主播] 当水果吃。
[嘉宾] 生蚝。
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 这个是展。
[嘉宾] 展的。
[主播] 啊，展的，生，展示的是吧？
[主播] 我们的生蚝不建议生吃啊。
[嘉宾] 近一点。
[主播] 拿近一点。
[主播] 看。
[主播] 给个近景大爷。
[主播] 生蚝真的很大。
[主播] 这是哪的生蚝现在？
[嘉宾] 之前我们卖那个。
[嘉宾] 乳山。
[嘉宾] 乳山的。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 这个送到保活吗？
[嘉宾] 保活。
[主播] 保活啊。
[主播] 嗯，这个送到保活吗？
[嘉宾] 保活。
[主播] 保活啊，那如果死了怎么办？
[嘉宾] 包赔。
[主播] 联系收货包赔。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 哇，真爽。
[主播] 柠檬汁。
[主播] 看这有。
[主播] 不影响，不影响。
[主播] 但大部分挤柠檬汁其实生，生吃生挤柠檬汁呢。
[主播] 我等会给你找个视频。
[主播] 我当时去巴塞罗那，地中海边嘛。
[主播] 有点辣包辣大壳的。
[主播] 然后去那个海鲜市场。
[主播] 他就是现场给你起。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 起开之后给你捏点柠檬。
[主播] 然后巴利从那会给倒出去，然后一喝。
[主播] 很鲜，特别鲜。
[主播] 但是不建议大量生吃，因为生吃肯定有寄生虫的，小孩不要生吃。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 成年人也不要生吃，生吃什么生吃？
[主播] 哇，这双头特别大。
[主播] 我这有水没事，不开了。
[主播] 挤上柠檬之后这个味道果然真的太棒了。
[主播] 我给你找找我那个视频。
[主播] 有朋友说单身狗不能吃生蚝。
[嘉宾] 为什么？
[主播] 骗我一次，错在你。
[主播] 骗我两次，错在我。
[主播] 那信你两次。
[主播] 我给你找找那个视频。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 等会给你个心情。
[主播] 这是当时在在巴塞罗那的时候。
[主播] 他给你刚起开的，还是活的。
[主播] 然后呢，我不知道要不要倒里头的水，但是我把那个给倒了。
[主播] 因为那是海水。
[主播] 新鲜的其实它不腥，然后捏一点柠檬。
[嘉宾] 啊？
[嘉宾] 它干净吗？
[主播] 都是那样吃的。
[嘉宾] 难以置信。
[主播] 懂我意思吗？
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 但是不建议生吃，不建议生吃，不要生吃。
[主播] 我们的这个可能标准是达不到的。
[主播] 而且就算能达到生吃里头肯定也有寄生虫啊，不建议。
[主播] 有朋友说给明明剩一个，没事还有呢，明明来再争。
[嘉宾] 明明粉丝不少啊。
[主播] 明明现在的粉丝特别多，明明的粉丝每天晚上跟我建议。
[嘉宾] 每次都他们都会说给明明留一点。
[主播] 真的是。
[主播] 昨晚很多明明的粉丝私信给我提出了很多非常直接深刻的工作建议。
[主播] 我一个个的回复收到，啊。
[主播] 董宇辉，我以前是因为认识你，认识的明明，但现在我只爱明明。
[主播] 好事，好事。
[主播] 生蚝箱子你拍了啊。
[主播] 什么价格导演？
[嘉宾] 88。
[嘉宾] 四斤。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 还行。
[主播] 都是这么大的对吧？
[嘉宾] 对，应该差不多三到四点五。
[主播] 哦。
[主播] 三到五两。
[嘉宾] 三到四点五两。
[主播] 保活。
[主播] 如果我收到是死的，我就联系客服给我赔。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 拍照就行，对吧？
[主播] 来，咱今天还有什么书，除了刚才那些？
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 大家想要听课了，我给大家讲一讲课。
[嘉宾] 我们有那个。
[嘉宾] 这几个都有。
[主播] 人类群星闪耀时，拿来。
[主播] 终于到了。
[主播] 给大家讲一讲拿破仑。
[主播] 大家对拿破仑真的是爱得深沉啊。
[主播] 好事，啊。
[主播] 好事，每天来读书学习。
[主播] 呃，把人类群星闪耀时那本书你们这没有是吧？
[嘉宾] 要不我们先讲这个吧。
[主播] 不，书在你到我公位上去取。
[主播] 你知道我公位不？
[嘉宾] 知道。
[主播] 对，你去吧，有一本红色皮的那个，人类群星闪耀时。
[主播] 大家说怎么了？
[主播] 什么时候去外面？
[主播] 呃，明天我们就会去平谷户外的。
[主播] 给平谷的果农们带桃。
[主播] 大家知道北京平谷的桃是非常出名的。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 然后呢，预计下星期可能就会去一次黑龙江。
[主播] 然后呢，俞老师这两天不是在云南吗？
[主播] 因为都得考察确定产品之后，得跟当地的一些商务厅啊，基本都是跟政府合作的。
[主播] 所以这样能够减少中间环节，尽可能让农民多挣钱。
[主播] 也是我们的初心嘛。
[主播] 然后呢，之前跟陕西省政府其实也商量过了，但是因为最近一段时间西安可能不太方便嘛。
[主播] 等过几天西安。
[主播] 哎，这些都已经敲定好了，啊。
[主播] 也希望有机会能够与大家相遇，啊。
[主播] 88大概几个刚才的这个生蚝？
[主播] 一个是三到四点五两，大概多少个一共？
[主播] 我可以算出来吗？
[主播] 88几斤？
[嘉宾] 四斤。
[主播] 四斤，一斤一个三到，那一个基本就是三个。
[主播] 是这意思吗？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 一斤就是三到四个。
[主播] 你说四斤。
[嘉宾] 一斤是二到三个。
[主播] 二到三个。
[嘉宾] 三个来算的话，四斤。
[主播] 那就是十个左右，八到十二，十个左右。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 大生蚝。
[主播] 差不多吧，现在这个季节买大生蚝差不多。
[主播] 人类群星闪耀是两本啊。
[主播] 都一样，都一样。
[主播] 大家需要自己拍，我之前给大家讲过这套书特别好，特别值得一读。
[主播] 尤其是你自己平常不知道读什么书。
[主播] 很多朋友私信我说老师啊，董老师，我特别想要培养一种一种知识的体系。
[主播] 就是很多人说感觉我在讲历史的时候，可以通过很多的瞬间把历史串起来一条线。
[主播] 当然这个其实是没有咱，这个真的是没有咱，我做不到。
[主播] 我能那样讲的一个主要原因其实是因为以前高中大家上过课里头都是那样讲的。
[主播] 人类历史何其漫长啊。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 我们短暂的一生七八十年，怎么可能把所有的事情都记在心里，是不可能做到的。
[主播] 也因此呢，
[主播] 稍等一下，稍等一下，不好意思。
[主播] 我们不可能把所有事情都记住。
[主播] 因此只能找到一些极其重要的瞬间放在那里头。
[主播] 那
[主播] 导演。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 给换本就行。
[主播] 所以我们只能通过一些记住非常重要的瞬间，通过那些瞬间把人类历史给贯穿起来。
[主播] 这些瞬间就是这本书记录的一些特点。
[主播] 它有两本，一个原稿其实是14个瞬间。
[主播] 这本书一共只选了10个瞬间。
[主播] 这种写的手法就跟前两天这个越南老师来给大家所写那个中国的那个历史一样。
[主播] 考古史一样。
[主播] 你不可能把几十年或者几十万年，甚至百万年的事情全部记录下来，你只能选一些重要瞬间去记录。
[主播] 那这些重要瞬间里都有什么呢？
[主播] 这里头讲到了几个，第一个，那天给大家讲到了土耳其人攻破了军事坦丁堡的陷落，对吧，记得吧？
[主播] 军事坦丁堡的陷落，啊。
[主播] 军事坦丁堡的陷落意味著欧洲的中世纪结束了，这是一个极具具有历史意义的一个时刻。
[主播] 中世纪结束了。
[主播] 中世纪结束之后的60年。
[主播] 这本书讲的第二个瞬间就是人类发现了太平洋。
[主播] 开始了这个环球航行。
[主播] 大家自己找一找啊。
[主播] 第二个紧接著就是巴尔沃亚，不朽的逃亡者，巴尔沃亚。
[主播] 第二个就是巴尔沃亚。
[主播] 前后两个事情之间隔了这个60年。
[主播] 如果大家要记住来，请你记住这个在历史上。
[主播] 非常重要的数字，如果你家里有孩子的话，这个数字尤其要记住。
[主播] 因为很多时候在学历史必须记住这个数字。
[主播] 就是1453年的5月29号，这一天军事坦丁堡陷落。
[主播] 然后就是我们所说的东东罗马帝国，或者说拜占庭帝国被攻破了。
[主播] 60年后这个叫做，那加个60，1513年。
[主播] 在1513年，然后9月25日，巴尔沃亚发现了我们现在所说的太平洋。
[主播] 但其实当时他把那个叫做大南洋。
[主播] 他把那叫大南洋。
[主播] 因为在那个之前哥伦布已经发现了这个美洲。
[主播] 但其实哥伦布当时把那个找错了。
[主播] 哥伦布以为他找到世界的东方。
[主播] 大家都渴望去世界的东方嘛，对我曾经给大家讲过为什么要去世界的东方。
[主播] 这块有世界地图吗？这只有中国地图。
[主播] 导演你帮我找一找世界地图。
[嘉宾] 好。
[主播] 对，帮我找找世界地图，把大家给这块把知识梳理清楚啊，再往后说。
[主播] 其实这些瞬间里头都是可以联系起来的。
[主播] 而且都可以联系到非常有意思的，非常有趣的知识。
[主播] 世界地图，对对对，就这个，拿来。
[主播] 对对对，谢谢，谢谢，来。
[主播] 我给大家展示一下，来你们可以边听边做笔记啊，来看这。
[主播] 看这啊。
[主播] 呃。
[主播] 大家说怎么了？
[主播] 考古类的书是几号链接？
[主播] 现在我给大家这本书叫做人类群星闪耀时，这本书就值得一读。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 这本书就值得一读。
[主播] 还有朋友说怎么了？
[主播] 考明明。
[主播] 明明一会几点来啊？
[嘉宾] 马上就来了。
[主播] 马上就来了，不急，大家等一会啊。
[主播] 我跟明明呢，我们俩真的是愿中兄弟。
[主播] 呃，之前给大家讲过，明明的舅妈是我大姨父的妹妹。
[主播] 所以我们俩。
[主播] 我觉得是有一种天然的亲近感的。
[主播] 而且在去年特别难那会，我们俩当时合租嘛。
[主播] 当然是合租啊，不是同居啊，中间隔著一堵墙呢。
[主播] 一起坚持到今天。
[主播] 也因为都来自同样的地方，明明小时候在商洛长大，那我外婆家就是商洛的。
[主播] 所以很多个平行时空里头可能我们俩是见过面的，但确实可能小时候没有打过招呼。
[主播] 后来在西安的时候他是初中的物理主管，我是高中的英语的教研主管。
[主播] 然后来到北京之后就一起共事。
[主播] 其实共事了很多年了，所以我们俩之间有一种互相理解。
[主播] 因为又有相同的生活经历，所以又极其的共情。
[主播] 然后呢，性格又很相似。
[主播] 对吧，都属于一种闷骚型的。
[主播] 所以又非常的懂懂对方吧。
[主播] 所以当然我们俩可能有时候在一块这个直播的时候显得比较放肆。
[主播] 胡说八道。
[主播] 他黑我，我黑他，互黑。
[主播] 其实这就像你跟你关系特别好的朋友之间的相处一样。
[主播] 对不对？
[主播] 当然有时候我比如说我们俩开玩笑，其实彼此心里没啥，但是观众们会心疼。
[主播] 观众们会说。
[主播] 董宇辉，你今天把我们家明明黑的太惨了，我说对不起，对不起。
[主播] 然后也有朋友给明明说，明明，你今天看董宇辉的时候眼神不对劲。
[主播] 明明说对不起，对不起。
[主播] 其实我们俩之间没啥，没啥。
[主播] 大家不用担心啊，没事。
[主播] 男生哪有那么多事情，没事，没事，来。
[主播] 之前世界从西，这个大家知道西汉，对吧？
[主播] 西汉。
[主播] 就是汉武帝大败匈奴之后，世界的。
[主播] 又在这里，西安，看到这个点了没？
[主播] 西安在这里啊。
[主播] 在这里。
[主播] 从这里一路货物沿著过了新疆的山脉之间的古地，一路走走走走，走到哪里呢？
[主播] 走到了。
[主播] 找一找。
[主播] 哎，找不到了。
[主播] 地方在哪？
[主播] 罗马，罗马在这，大家看这啊。
[主播] 这个点，看到这个点了没？
[主播] 罗马特别小，发现没，这个黑点。
[主播] 我给你顿个黑点啊。
[主播] 人们就把香料、丝绸、茶叶跨过了漫长的大路线，一直送到了罗马。
[主播] 东西之间的交流是正常的，是顺畅的。
[主播] 所以历史也是稳定的。
[主播] 但是后来，你看他这个过程是不是要经历土耳其这里啊？
[主播] 要经历我们现在所说的这个中亚。
[主播] 所以后来随著土耳其人的崛起，土耳其人占领了这里，我们所说的这个，你看现在这，这，看这，导演这。
[主播] 伊斯坦布尔。
[主播] 进景啊，足够近的进景，非常近的进景。
[主播] 近到极致了没现在？
[主播] 已经近的极致了，这个镜头不行啊。
[主播] 这伊斯坦布尔，伊斯坦布尔就是我们所说的军事坦丁堡陷落了。
[主播] 就是刚才所说的1453年陷落了。
[主播] 所以你看从长安来的货物一路都走到这了，但是过不去，到不了罗马。
[主播] 土耳其人崛起之后，陆地没有办法再走通了，所以欧洲人又很渴望瓷器、丝绸和香料、茶叶。
[主播] 所以他们只能，而且他们听完马可波罗跟你说墙上都是宝石，头顶都是金子，房顶都是金子，他们太期待了。
[主播] 所以他们就想著，比如说绕过这个非洲，绕过好望角，从这过印度洋，然后到中国呢。
[主播] 第一个认知走到这块，刚过来就回去了。
[主播] 第一个认知走到这。
[主播] 都没到印度洋就回去了。
[主播] 第二个人呢，直接一出港就被风刮刮跑了，从那绕了一圈绕到哪去了，绕到这来去了。
[主播] 第二个人是谁呀？
[主播] 哥伦布。
[主播] 所以哥伦布其实他直接跑错了，他跑到这来了。
[主播] 但他以为自己走对，他以为他来到，他以为来到印度或者中国了呢。
[主播] 因为当时大家都喜欢印度的，也有茶叶嘛，对吧，中国也有茶叶，丝器香料这些，印度也有大量的香料嘛。
[主播] 他其实跑错了。
[主播] 但他不知道呀。
[主播] 所以他看著这边土著人头上射箭那些人，头上插著羽毛，他管他叫Indians。
[主播] 这就能解释为什么现在美洲的人民叫印第安人呢？
[主播] Indians其实是不是印度人的意思啊？
[主播] 他跑错了，他以为他到印度了，所以把这块叫Indians。
[主播] 但是呢，他盛名在外，你又不能站起来说他错了。
[主播] 对不对？
[主播] 就是你要挑战前辈的权威的时候，有时候冒著生命危险的。
[主播] 所以巴尔沃亚当年到这里的时候。
[主播] 他把这片路叫新大陆。
[主播] 但他自己心里知道这不是我们要找的中国与印度，不是世界的东方。
[主播] 他没有办法。
[主播] 他就说这叫新大陆。
[主播] 巴尔沃亚其实是一个，现在用现在的话来说，其实是一个罪犯嘛。
[主播] 他其实是戴罪立功的。
[主播] 他想要迅速的挣钱，他想要占有这些殖民地，因为当时呢，只要你占有了这里，这个钱就属于你了。
[主播] 他想要占领这片。
[主播] 然后他从这之后过了现在的这个中美这里。
[主播] 然后第一次他看见了这片海洋。
[主播] 所以这片海洋是欧洲人发现的最晚的，就是世界上最大这片海洋叫做太平洋。
[主播] 他是发，他是欧洲人发现最晚的。
[主播] 他在发现之后的，他当时管这片海叫做大南洋，他其实并没有把这个定义为太平洋，他叫大南洋。
[主播] 直到好多年后。
[主播] 好几年后也没有好多年后。
[主播] 麦哲伦完成了第一次人类的环球航行。
[主播] 他从欧洲出发，过去绕著大西洋，绕到了这个美洲，从美洲过来之后走到了太平洋。
[主播] 从太平洋这块过来，然后又走印度洋，走印度洋之后又从大西洋回到了欧洲。
[主播] 那是巴尔沃亚发现了太平洋之后的几年。
[主播] 人类第一次才完成了环球航行。
[主播] 所以其实太平洋我们一直就知道，但欧洲人发现的是特别晚的。
[主播] 但这本书里头他给你说的是人类发现的最后一块大洋是太平洋。
[主播] 那其实他所说的人类就是以他们的视角去看的，对吧？
[主播] 我们当然知道太平洋的存在啊。
[主播] 所以这是刚才这块。
[主播] 那我们接下来再继续说，来请大家在评论区回答我。
[主播] 哪一年军事坦丁堡陷落，回答我。
[主播] 回答我哪一年军事坦丁堡陷落，快。
[主播] 哪一年军事坦丁堡陷落？
[主播] 我刚才说过，你看这朋友又忘了。
[主播] 教了半天发现只把自己教明白。
[主播] 董宇辉，我要不回答问题，你真以为你自己教的很好呢。
[主播] 来，1453年，记住这个日子。
[主播] 1453年军事坦丁堡陷落，军事坦丁堡在哪？这这，伊斯坦布尔。
[主播] 罗马在这。
[主播] 罗马在这，军事坦丁堡在这，长安在这。
[主播] 那些骆驼商队带著丝绸、茶叶、瓷器一路走走走走，走到这的时候被拦住了。
[主播] 走到这拦住，因为土耳其人拦住的，他们走不过去了。
[主播] 他们当时路线是这样子的。
[主播] 才能到罗马。
[主播] 走不过气，丝绸过不去，茶叶过不去。
[主播] 欧洲人想要的东西过不去。
[主播] 你知道丝绸和茶叶在欧洲是多么受欢迎吗？
[主播] 越禁止的东西越受欢迎。
[主播] 你知道当时其实在罗马大家是禁止丝绸的，为什么？因为他们原来穿的东西，比如说羊毛或者是麻布也其实比较比较大比较硬的。
[主播] 显示不出你的身材。
[主播] 但是丝绸是不是很柔软，很轻薄，甚至你的身材都能看见。
[主播] 因为在宗教里头大家觉得啊，那看到你身材不好，甚至觉得就要禁止，对不对？
[主播] 他甚至是一个让人引起不好幻想的东西。
[主播] 但是越进越受欢迎，因为丝绸很轻盈，穿上很美，很舒服。
[主播] 丝绸都是贵族才穿的。
[主播] 当时能够用瓷器去喝茶叶的，都是真的都是贵族，都有钱人。
[主播] 所以大家对这个的渴望忍不住，而且这个马可波罗从中国回来之后告诉你。
[主播] 北，就是现在的北京，上都当时元的首都嘛。
[主播] 然后呢，墙上都是金子，房顶都是宝石，大家忍不住呀。
[主播] 找找找，终于经过了60年的探索。
[主播] 60年，刚才回答151453。
[主播] 那哪一年发现了太平洋？
[主播] 加上60是多少？
[主播] 加上60是多少？请大家回答我。
[主播] 有朋友说董宇辉你是没有眼睛吗？我一直在问，有。
[主播] 你把你屏幕截个图搓大，你看到一个缝隙啊。
[主播] 1513年，1513年，非常棒，非常棒。
[主播] 大家今天记住两个数字，第一个叫1453是军事坦丁堡陷落的时间。
[主播] 军事坦丁堡陷落之后，土耳其把人把这个名字改成了伊斯坦布尔。
[主播] 当然在周杰伦的歌里头大家听过，他们写的方面叫这个伊斯坦堡，我来到伊斯坦堡，就像是童话故事有教堂有城堡。
[主播] 听过吧？
[主播] 不同地方翻译不一样嘛。
[主播] 然后呢，大家看这块。
[主播] 所以经过了60年，因为陆地不再贯通的时候，人类就想要去发现海洋的文明。
[主播] 所以东西的交流和人们之间的互通其实是非常重要的。
[主播] 只要中间有停顿，人类就会找到新的方式。
[主播] 也是因为这个人类开始了航海大探索，然后文艺复兴启蒙运动之后，欧洲是不是开始普通的百姓，他们对于这个科技的掌握和知识的掌握也来多了。
[主播] 民主的掌握也来多了之后，人们就要开始探索一个更好的社会的雏形了。
[主播] 那最欧洲最喜欢闹革命的哪个国家？
[主播] 动不动就游行罢工的时代。
[主播] 法国。
[主播] 有一个段子。
[主播] 欧洲最喜欢到高面的
[主播] 是哪个国家？动不动就游行罢工的是的。
[主播] 法国。
[主播] 法国人有一个段子，我不知道你们听过没啊，有一个，当然这个可能有点略微有点羞辱性。
[主播] 说没有人能够在法国人投降之前占领巴黎。
[主播] 听过这句话没？
[主播] 你知道为什么？
[主播] 你还没有打到巴黎他们就投降了。
[主播] 二战他们有多少人投降的吗？
[主播] 39天还是49天。
[主播] 说没有人能够再占领巴黎之前。
[主播] 在法国人投降之前占领巴黎。
[主播] 你还没到，我就投降了。
[主播] 这本书大家自己看。
[主播] 明明已经来了，明明在旁边等我的，明明给我一会胡说八道的时间。
[主播] 然后呢，所以
[主播] 大家现在就经常，对吧？
[主播] 日常的拿法国人开玩笑，但是这也是对他们的爱啊，对他们的爱主要是。
[主播] 法国历史上曾经非常强盛过。
[主播] 所以这本书再往后讲到的是谁？
[主播] 讲到了
[主播] 拿破仑。
[主播] 讲到了当时当时看似这个民主，但是给社会带来了混乱和人们生活痛苦的时候，拿破仑出现了。
[主播] 拿破仑是多大称的帝？
[主播] 拿破仑是多大，多大年龄的时候称的帝？
[主播] 大家记得不？
[主播] 拿破仑多大年龄称的帝？
[嘉宾] 那个10,10几，10几。
[主播] 拿破仑是多大首称的帝？
[主播] 拿破仑是35岁称的帝。
[主播] 那是哪一年呢？
[主播] 拿破仑称帝的那一年是哪一年？
[主播] 我看这本书里头有没有。
[主播] 是不是没有？这本书讲的是滑铁卢战争的时候，他战败的时候。
[主播] 拿破仑35岁称的帝。
[主播] 那一年是不是不是1804年啊，1804年。
[主播] 不知道的朋友再回复第三个数字。
[主播] 1804年。
[主播] 拿破仑35岁，他开始称帝了。
[主播] 虽然拿破仑称帝，大家现在感觉到一般称帝我们反而是不是历史的倒退啊，但其实法国人当时很赞同的。
[主播] 因为在拿破仑之前那个看似民主，但是极其混乱，给人们带来痛苦的政府，法国人对当时那个并不欢迎。
[主播] 所以拿破仑当时其实挺得民心的啊。
[主播] 就是你只要真正让普通百姓过得好，对吧？
[主播] 大家在意的是每一天的幸福呀。
[主播] 拿破仑称帝了。
[主播] 但是从1804年称帝到1814年，他第一次被流放到厄尔巴岛上。
[主播] 这十年里头，拿破仑没有一年是平静的过生活的。
[主播] 每一年都在打仗，每一年都在打仗。
[主播] 这头，这第三次反法同盟。
[主播] 第四次反法同盟。
[主播] 第五次反法同盟。
[主播] 直到第六次反法同盟。
[主播] 第六次反法同盟失败的一个原因是因为从1812年之后。
[主播] 拿破仑从原来的保护自己。
[主播] 为什么他要保护自己？
[主播] 因为你想。
[主播] 拿破仑推翻了原来法国的皇帝路易10,路易10几？
[主播] 14,16。
[主播] 路易14。
[嘉宾] 14。
[主播] 14应该是。
[嘉宾] 16。
[主播] 拿破仑推翻了原来的法国皇帝之后，其他欧洲的皇帝很担心呀。
[主播] 就是如果我看到大家整个欧洲人看到了。
[主播] 有人说是14,有人是16。
[主播] 应该是16,我记得啊。
[主播] 如果其他的欧洲国家人们看到了说，法国的皇帝竟然可以被砍头，那其他人也可以被砍头。
[主播] 所以其他欧洲正常的那些原来的皇帝们就很紧张。
[主播] 所以就组成了反法同盟。
[主播] 这头只要是来欺负法国的。
[主播] 你一定有谁？
[主播] 你一定有英国。
[主播] 因为大家知道英国跟法国是仇嘛，对吧？
[主播] 英法战争曾经打了百年。
[主播] 英国，然后呢，再包括后来大家所知道的这个其他的国家，当然其中一个主力就是当时的沙俄，他们每次就组成各种各样的这个反法联盟。
[主播] 一次又一次，一次又一次。
[主播] 然后在这之前的拿破仑的战争其实主要还是正义性的，因为他要保护自己的这个成果，保护自己的国民。
[主播] 但到1812年的开始，他是进攻了一次俄罗斯。
[主播] 他带过去的据说有50万之众的部队。
[主播] 但是一经攻到莫斯科的时候。
[主播] 他没有想到俄罗斯人会那样的，就是把城一烧。
[主播] 人就往后退。
[主播] 他一路打过来之后需要补给的时候，发现这是一座烧的空空荡荡的城，什么都没有。
[主播] 然后又正好逢到了冬天，零下几十度啊。
[主播] 你想俄罗斯的冬天多冷。
[主播] 所以回来之后士气还有元气都大伤。
[主播] 所以在这个之后，他逐渐就开始很难恢复到原备有的样子了。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 在1814年第六次反法同盟的时候。
[主播] 拿破仑就失败了。
[主播] 失败之后他被流放到一个岛上，但是离法国很近的岛叫什么？叫厄尔巴岛。
[主播] 这个时候于是就产生了非常经典的一句，哎，我是不是已经到明明的时间了？
[主播] 我是不是已经占他时间了？
[嘉宾] 没事，你讲。
[嘉宾] 再讲讲。
[主播] 我把这句话说完。
[嘉宾] 没事，再讲半个小时。
[主播] 你别，你别，你别快，赶快来。
[主播] 你先来你站着，或者省得一会大家想你，大家都这在呼吁你呢。
[主播] 有一句话是这样子的，叫做Able
[嘉宾] 这个吗？
[主播] was I
[主播] I saw Elba。
[主播] 这是非常经典的一句名言，大家看说Able was I
[主播] 什么意思？就是在我看见厄尔巴岛，这个是古中世纪的英语，它叫表示什么什么之前，它相当于大家所学过的before一样。
[主播] 这句话极其经典。
[主播] 学英语的人应该都听过这句话，说在我看见厄尔巴岛之前，我无所不能。
[主播] 但是这句话后来我特别喜欢一个翻译家叫谁？许渊冲老师。
[主播] 许渊冲老师当年在北大的课堂上给孩子们翻译过这个版本。
[主播] 这句话平常翻译叫做在我看见厄尔巴岛之前，我无所不能。
[主播] 许渊冲老师翻译的版本叫做。
[主播] 不到
[主播] 我们翻译为厄尔巴岛。
[主播] 或者叫做俄尔巴岛也行，啊。
[主播] 许老师翻译叫做不到俄岛。
[主播] 不到俄岛我不倒。
[主播] 你看。
[主播] 许老师翻译就是，所以你看他不止是英语好，法语好。
[主播] 他中文更好。
[主播] 不到俄岛我不倒。
[主播] 你发现没？
[主播] 在我没有到这个岛上之前，我是从未倒下过的。
[主播] 对吧？我是令整个欧洲闻风丧胆的人。
[主播] 我挫败了他们六次的联合攻击。
[主播] 我甚至昨天打着西班牙又现在打着反法同盟呢。
[主播] 但是他被流放到厄尔巴岛。
[主播] 厄尔巴岛上之后，他中间大概停了几个月就逃回了法国。
[主播] 这段就特别经典了。
[主播] 逃回法国的路上。
[主播] 然后呢，一路遇见了被路易18皇帝，就是原来那个皇帝，这个原来的王朝派来的皇帝去阻碍他的部队的时候。
[主播] 每次在路上只要见到了，拿破仑就问说。
[主播] 你确定要与我为战吗？
[主播] 你确定要与你们曾经这个尊重的拿破仑皇帝为战吗？
[主播] 那些人就反听完之后，这不是我的男神啊。
[主播] 这是偶像，这我战神啊。
[主播] 对吧，这是我们在欧洲立起来的人啊。
[主播] 大家纷纷倒戈。
[主播] 所以拿破仑就一路走一路把那些本要注定阻碍他的人收编到他的部队里，重新又夺回来。
[主播] 然后接下来他就面临了最后一次第17次，第不是第，第七次反法同盟。
[主播] 怎么能说17?
[主播] 第七次反法同盟。
[主播] 但这次实力悬殊特别大。
[主播] 实力悬殊特别大。
[主播] 拿破仑的部队根本没有反法同盟的部队人是多了。
[主播] 但是有时候也看历史怎么选择你呢？
[主播] 拿破仑以少胜多的战役也不是没有。
[主播] 大家知道他在20多岁的时候曾经就。
[主播] 打过埃及。
[主播] 那个时候2.5万的法军打败了10万的埃及部队。
[主播] 所以拿破仑是非常有能力，而且有经验能够以少胜多的。
[主播] 但是在第七次的时候，究竟发生了什么？
[主播] 我不耽搁大家时间，已经到10点了。
[主播] 晚上我继续给大家讲这本改变人类历史的十个瞬间，人类群星闪耀时。
[主播] 当然这本书你准备上一个两万库存左右。
[主播] 晚上我再讲，好吧？
[主播] 我们欢迎明明啊。
[主播] 别跑啊，跑这。
[嘉宾] 拿破仑还没讲完是吧？
[主播] 没讲完没讲完。
[主播] 这个再拖下去就拖时间太长了，不好。
[主播] 这个书导演说书已经没人卖不动了都。
[嘉宾] 卖不动了。
[主播] 对，那晚上再讲一部。
[嘉宾] 晚上再讲。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 讲一个你可以撤。
[主播] 生蚝，有生蚝没拿上来，没吃点。
[主播] 生蚝特别好吃，生蚝。
[嘉宾] 赶紧给明明补一补。
[主播] 赶紧给什么补一补？
[嘉宾] 给他补一补。
[主播] 什么这两天熬夜班呢？
[嘉宾] 这个吃了。
[嘉宾] 昨天一天框吃框吃吃了四个海参。
[主播] 你吃了四个海参。
[嘉宾] 我我我不知道这个一底线只能吃一个，然后我吃的过程中朋友在提醒我，玩这一天只能吃一个。
[主播] 看你来晚了，我把三个大的都吃了。
[嘉宾] 然后就吃了四个。
[嘉宾] 紧跟上他们就说四个海参，一个反正两个夜班，你自己算。
[嘉宾] 然后就给自己又争取了八个夜班。
[主播] 所以说师傅的福气都在后头呢，而且都是靠自己努力。
[主播] 一点一点就。
[嘉宾] 靠自己努力挣来的。
[主播] 一点一点努力挣来的。
[其他] 明天你俩谁去直播啊？
[主播] 我去。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 明天吗？
[主播] 明天苹果。
[主播] 明天苹果的桃，如果大家想桃的话，明天期待啊。
[主播] 给他换了一个筷子是吧？
[主播] 好。
[嘉宾] 对。
[嘉宾] 在咱们这个号播还是再别的？
[主播] 在这个号中间应该会连麦过来的这事。
[嘉宾] 味道好吃啊。
[主播] 乳山生蚝啊。
[主播] 想的朋友自己拍。
[主播] 这个88块钱，对吧？
[主播] 这生蚝到乳山。
[嘉宾] 到手约12个左右啊。
[嘉宾] 都大的。
[主播] 我给大家看它确实大。
[主播] 这是取开了一半的生蚝。
[嘉宾] 明明你不给你兄弟一会，你是刚来不知道。
[嘉宾] 我兄弟刚才把三个大的都炫了。
[主播] 他兄弟炫了三个大的。
[主播] 给他留了俩小的。
[主播] 不你还有一会给大家可以再蒸一些。
[嘉宾] 开四包牌，开四包牌。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 快四包牌。
[嘉宾] 再四包牌。
[嘉宾] 这个回去很好做啊，上面拿那个刷子。
[嘉宾] 其实这还算干净啊。
[嘉宾] 把这稍微刷一下。
[主播] 还是得刷，要不然蒸完之后锅里全是沙子。
[嘉宾] 对对对，但这个不是很多。
[嘉宾] 拿刷子把这个外边一刷，刷完之后往锅里边一放一蒸就完事了。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 然后是不是还送个刀啊什么之类的？
[嘉宾] 好刀什么有没有？
[主播] 应该是有好刀的吧？
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 算了，这个我也吃了吧，别浪费了。
[主播] 你吃你吃。
[主播] 还有应该还有这个对吧？
[主播] 晚上如果再播到的，还可以再蒸一些。
[主播] 因为生蚝它送到之后，你就赶快吃，也别放。
[主播] 因为你送到肯定它很快就死了。
[主播] 你这时候吃它口感还好。
[嘉宾] 它的保质期冷藏的话，大概几天，大家尽快吃到啊。
[主播] 你放的时间久了，它口感会越来越差，而且那个腥味就出来了，其实新鲜的生蚝是不腥的。
[主播] 海边的人都知道这个事。
[嘉宾] 说到赶紧吃，这个不能放，放时间长，它这个口就张开了，口张开就就代表已经死了，就不行了。
[嘉宾] 再一个呢，是不要寄希望于自己在家里倒点水能把这个养几天是不行的，它需要那种海水的环境。
[嘉宾] 所以有时候你到一些线下门店去买的时候，他为了让你养，他会给你带点海水。
[主播] 其实那那个水他们是按着海水的比例调的。
[嘉宾] 对，按着海水的盐度比去调的。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 但即使是那种拿回去其实也养不了多久。
[嘉宾] 两三天。
[嘉宾] 就不行了。
[主播] 如果你比如说今天你中午收到了，你就把它做了，但是晚上大家才能回来。
[主播] 你可以是这样，比如你蒸好之后放到碗里。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 好的。
[主播] 蒸好之后放在碗里，把酱汁调好，晚上回来大家一会去吃也行。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 我就不在这捣乱了。
[主播] 他说我一直这咽口水，真的忍不住了。
[主播] 定个饭去。
[嘉宾] 好，赶紧去吃饭。
[嘉宾] 一会几点？
[主播] 呃，我今天晚上是几点？
[嘉宾] 今天晚上
[嘉宾] 在我前边应该是。
[嘉宾] 7点45。
[主播] 还是7点45到10点多。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 守夜人。
[嘉宾] 嗯，守夜人。
[主播] 这个这个那电视就啥？Game of Thrones,冰与火之歌里头的那个。
[嘉宾] 哦。
[主播] 城墙上的守夜人。
[主播] 北境守夜人。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 给明明多吃点生蚝。
[主播] 吃一个生蚝，手一信息。
[主播] 晚上把剩下生蚝全部给明明一蒸。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 拜拜。
[嘉宾] 我这7月包了，8月都包了。
[嘉宾] 嗯。